-You mentioned that
"Dinner with the Gaffigans
is raising money for those
in the medical community.
Obviously you are coming off
a recent very scary period
of your life
where the medical communit
was really helpful to you.
Your wife had a brain tumor, and
now she's doing great, right
-She's doing great.
I mean, it does --
Following the surgery,
she did contract pneumonia
So she's considered
in that high-risk element.
So essentially,
as I mentioned earlier,
we're on like this double secret
quarantine where, you know
we rarely even get delivery,
food deliveries.
But I will -- At the end o
every day I will go down
and get boxes
and empty the garbage.
I call that my "me" time.
You know, then I just come bac
up and I yell at my children
So, yeah, no,
it's a pretty scary time.
But I think
we all have to be vigilant
Obviously, you know,
I might complain,
but compared to the sacrific
that, you know,
even a delivery person
is dealing with,
is so much more difficult
and so much more scary.
But it's alright.
-This is a scary time
for everyone.
But there is this sort of
collective sense
that we're going through i
together.
I have to imagine
a couple of years ago
when your wife
was going through that,
that must have been really
terrifying for your kids.
-Yeah, you know, it is
interesting, because for m
it's very reminiscent of
that time period,
where obviously now the worl
has shut down, but, you know
when my wife went through
this brain surgery,
our world shut down.
And so the career is canceled,
the -- everything, you know,
you just focus on the children
You know,
you kind of are a morale -
I mean, I'm much more of
a short-order cook at this point
and a janitor than what I wa
when my wife was sick.
But yeah, no,
it is very reminiscent.
And there is part of me
that is also very --
this is going to
sound really corny --
but there is something about -
there's an opportunity
for this one-on-one time.
-I feel this weird thing
that my kids, again,
they're two and four,
you know, when this is over,
and hopefully it'll be
sooner than later,
it'll be jarring for them.
They're enjoying the fact
that they're spending so muc
time with their parents.
-Yeah.
There is something
about this experience
that as a parent is very vital
I mean, you know, I joke aroun
and I'm like,
I always said I wanted to spen
more time with my kids,
and you've got to be careful
what you wish for.
You know, in a sincere way
there is something --
this is going to shape them.
You know, like, I look at
my children and I think,
this is the generation
that has encountered
an enormous amount of fear
whether it be my teenagers
or my 10-year-old, that,
you know, when I was growing up,
I didn't have to deal with that.
I mean, there was this kind of
fear of a war with Russia.
But this is, you know, a ver
kind of serious, sobering thin
that they're experiencing as
teenagers, which is fascinating.
I think it's making
the whole country grow up.
Hopefully we're like, "Okay,
we need the adults in charge
we need to listen to science
we need adults in charge."